un correcteur encore quelques détails
techniques à régler et les 15 ha
tablettes numériques sont prêtes pour
l'expérimentation ce lundi matin au
retour de la récréation
c'était un peu noël avant l'heure pour
les élèves de l'école ernest bizet de
saint cyr nous allons nous les partager
au niveau de l'école voilà on va essayer
de travailler avec vous avez quels
usages moins possible avec les
applications est émise par le crdp
donc on va on va découvrir en même temps
à je vais découvrir en même temps que
les enfants ce qui a pu être mis dessus
dessus les applications de traitement de
texte des jeux de mathématiques histoire
géographie sciences est aussi une
connexion internet pour les élèves en
binôme la prise en main des bijoux
technologiques
c'est facile comme un jeu d'enfant
on voit que les enfants collaborent
beaucoup plus vous voyez des enfants du
travail à deux et donc à ce moment là on
voit des enfants qui collaborent des
enfants qui travaillent ensemble et qui
sont beaucoup plus motivés
je souhaite vraiment rentré dans les
apprentissages beaucoup plus facilement
de son côté la maîtresse avoue avoir
encore des difficultés à apprivoiser
l'outil numérique pour s'en servir de
manière éducative
surtout que les tablettes tactiles
peuvent aussi se connecter au tableau
numérique interactif
l'enseignant peut demander aux élèves
des résultats en calcul mental les
élèves remplissent complète sur la
tablette et tout est envoyé directement
aux techniques ont avec des boîtiers de
vote et l'enseignant a tout de suite le
résultat l'image de sa classe
l'expérimentation prendra fin en juin
un bilan sera alors dressé pour
envisager dès la rentrée 2013
une généralisation de tablette numérique
dans les écoles élémentaires
participantes au projet pour l'heure
difficile de canaliser les technophiles
en herbe
mais pas question pour la maîtresse
d'oublier les problèmes de mathématiques
inscrits au tableau de créer dans les
livres papier